remember how much of my life my
childhood was seeing you know you on All
in the Family and how that was a
cultural event um you being on Johnny or
uh your films on SNL there was you
talked about it you know it would happen
on a it would happen and then you'd
you'd all talk about it my friends who
were into comedy and I would talk about
it in Brooklyn Mass well think about
think about this talk about appointment
television Saturday live when it first
came
on that's a Saturday night that and you
you had to watch it when it was on and
it was you know it was on 11:30 and
11:30 in on the west coast kids young
people in parties would stop whatever
they were doing and watch Saturday night
and that that you know also I think we
have to bring this up because it's in
the dock and it's something I did not
know which is that you were approached
by uh by
Lauren and dick Abol dick Abol wonderful
wonderful man
uh yeah you have you you have a great
love for him don't you you know I know
about his knowledge of Comedy is
stunning uh um uh anyway um what a he's
on the Rushmore he's on the r he's on
Mount Rushmore um but anyway uh those
guys approached you about building SNL
around you and you said I think and
that's and and you said I think that's
well I here's the thing I you know it's
50 years ago and I'm maybe Lauren has
another memory of it but it wasn't that
complicated uh in the fall of
74 I went to a meeting and they they
said because that was Johnny Carson's
rerun night and they said we're going to
stop doing that we're going to put an
original show we want to do it live from
New York and we'd like it to be Albert
Brook show you you would be the host now
I had flirted with television twice
before and thank
God the way the life works I didn't do
it uh one about two and a half years
earlier I got offered my own summer show
on CBS six shows and I mean it's was
going to be the Albert Brook show what
what what kind of show will it be I was
you know really starting to think there
were offices we got offices and then I
was asked to Carol berett who was the
big CBS star was honored and I was asked
to perform at the event and I didn't
have a lot of stuff I had bits that I
did from the road one of which was on my
album comedy minus one not to be
confused with Godzilla minus
one somebody said is that where you play
part of a monster I
said I don't I don't have
any but but so I performed that and I
did this bit that I did on my record
where if you're a comedian and you're
performing in the South and you're
bombing then you have that fail safe you
dig deep and you come out and you
pronounce it clearly and you somehow get
out the word
and that
turns everything around they laugh for
20 minutes I said people run out they
build a statue in the park you know and
so basically it was saved my life
so the next day I get a call and William
paly called my agency and said this foul
mouth young man will not appear on my
network yeah so I didn't do that so and
then earlier on I was going to do a
sitcom that I backed out of in a meeting
where that was already a go Aaron
Spelling was producing it it was a whole
season approved and Michael Eisner the
last question said well let me ask
Albert though what do you see for this
character in five years and I said
suicide and and I I stood up and I said
I'm not ready this is not going to work
and I left and the Agents follow me into
the elevator and one of them and said
you should wait you should wait and the
other said I don't think it's a good he
should do it and and so after those two
I was done with television I wanted to
make movies so a I wasn't going to do
the Albert Brook show but I also thought
that they were talking to somebody from
Los Angeles and when they said we're
doing a live show at 11:30 in New York
to me live meant nothing there it was no
live I didn't see anything that I wasn't
supposed to see if somebody in New York
said a swear word it was you mean like
it was cut out long before I saw it
so I had a couple of thoughts I said
well wouldn't it make more sense I mean
The Tonight Show in essence is live they
never stop what if you did one at 4:30
and one at 7:30 and put the best
together to air but they wanted live and
obviously it worked it was a you know
but I knew that I would be John balushi
I'd be on eight grams of coke I I'm not
good starting at 11:30 it's why I hated
the road I never got that third show at
midnight it just didn't make sense to me
it's too late too too much so I said I
you know and and I said you know every
show has the same host you should use
different hosts each week so they said
okay well thanks for coming in then four
months went by they hadn't done anything
yet they came back to me we want you
associated with the show what do you
want to do I said I want to do short
films so I made an agreement to do it I
did them here and for that in the spring
of 75 Lauren and I did the national
junket in those days they would take the
Sheridan Universal and every reporter
would have a different room and they'd
set up the room so they could pretend
you came to them yes so you'd walk into
a room there'd be this fake palm tree
Albert Brooks welcome to Fort Lauderdale
thank you wow it's sweaty out there you
know they they loved if you played along
sure yeah and it was the same interview
so you're going to make short films for
a new show I am what's the show about I
don't really know here's the producer
ask Lauren and he didn't know at that
moment What's the show about well we're
going to have the new kind of comedy and
it's going to be new and that so then
from that point Lauren got his Prime
Time Players and he built this show that
has been the longest running show in
television so obviously he did it
perfectly but that that's the way it
went
down